the former head of USA Gymnastics is in
custody in Tennessee this morning for
alleged evidence tampering in the last
larry nasser sexual abuse case
Steve penny was indicted by a grand jury
in Texas now he's accused of luring
documents to be taken from the Curley
ranch
that's where elite gymnasts trained and
NASA victims say that they were abused
the felony count carries a possible 10
years in prison Tony to cope was here
with new details on this case Tony good
morning good morning Steve penny is one
of several former USA Gymnastics
officials accused of covering up years
of sexual abuse by team dr. Larry Nasser
you recall in January he was sentenced
to up to 175 years in prison now NASA's
victims have argued for years that penny
enabled Nasser's behavior and that he
and other Olympic officials need to be
held accountable
last night former USA Gymnastics
president Steve penny was taken into
custody by deputy US Marshals accused of
tampering with evidence at the famed
Karolyi ranch the grand jury indictment
alleges penny ordered the removal of
documents related to dr. Nasser's
activities there and had them delivered
to penny at the USA Gymnastics
headquarters in Indianapolis it's all
part of an ongoing investigation into a
possible cover-up of Nasser's conduct at
the ranch they knew they had to have
known they knew everything else about
everything else we were doing Olympic
bronze medalist Jamie dancer and former
team USA member Jeanette antolín are
among several former gymnast that
believe Olympic coaches Bella and Martha
Karolyi knew about Nasser's abuse but
did nothing to stop it they knew that he
was coming into our rooms if they didn't
know that we were being abused they
still knew that a grown man was coming
into a child's room at nighttime by
himself the Corollas have denied they
knew about Nasser's abuse at the time
but in a sworn deposition Martha Karolyi
said penny alerted her to nassos
behavior in 2015 did the corrals know
that somebody was coming to the ranch to
remove documents I think that question
needs to be asked John Manley represents
180 of Nasser's accusers
he says a broader investigation of the
u.s. Olympic Committee and USA
gymnastics is required there needs to be
subpoenas served search warrant served
and testimony given hopefully this is
the tip of the iceberg
you know Steve penny is not the only
person who covered this love man Lee
says dozens of children were abused by
NASA after penny admitted in 2015 that
he knew about nashor's abuse USA
Gymnastics did not get back to us but
the US Olympic Committee says it
cooperates with every investigation to
provide a safe and positive environment
for athletes Penny's lawyer meanwhile
says his client is confident that when
all the facts are known it will show
that he did nothing criminal john tonydd
a couple thank you Tony it just keeps
going